على مدى سنوات القليله الماضيه شهدت ايران
هجمات عدى استهدف بعضها منشات النوويه
واخرى عسكريه اضافه الى اختيار عدد من
الشخصيات في الخامس والعشرين من يوليو
2020 وقع انفجار في منطقه خزير في بارجين
التي تضم منشات عسكريه وصاروخيه ايرانيه
في نوفمبر عام 2020 اغتيل العالم النووي
محسن فخري زاد في مدينه
دماوند قربنا واتهمت ايران اسرائيل
بالوقوفه وراء العمليه في فبراير 2022
وقعا انفجار في مركز للمسيرات التابعه
للحارس الثوري الايراني في منطقه ما هي
دشت في مدينه كارمن شاه غربي البلاد في
الثانيه والعشرين من مايو الماضي اختنا
العقيد في الحارس التولي صياد برصاص
مسلحين مشغولين في طهران اثناء عودته الى
منزله في الخامس والعشرين من مايو ايه
لقيا مهندس ايراني حدفه واصيب موظف اخر في
حادثا بمركز ابحاث في موقع برجين العسكري
اتابع لوزاره الدفاع عن الايرانيه